would love to hear more detail of a
hypothesis that Brett mentioned on Joe
Rogan how society repeats patterns of
opportunity distribution what I said was
it projects them into the future so for
example if you have a population if
black folks accumulate in one part of
town for various reasons right because
they've been frozen out of economic
opportunity and the houses in that part
of town are more affordable something
like that you just have people
accumulate as we know neighborhoods do
tend to accumulate different ethnicities
and all you have that and then you have
redlining
right and that redlining creates a
viscosity an economic viscosity that
prevents the accumulation of further
wealth at some point the neighborhood
itself has a small tax base it can't
produce high quality schools the
inability to produce high quality
schools tends to hobble the kids who go
to those schools it's not hard to see
how things that came out of Jim Crow
became ever more subtle and more
structural and might cause people in
that neighborhood to face a steeper
uphill climb to get to a different
economic strata right so what it does is
it simply projects the past pattern into
the future and thereby even if you do
away with the racism which we largely
have you still have a pattern as if that
old racism was still in force because
what you've done is you have not brought
everybody to the starting line and said
okay now that we've done away with the
racism and now that we've done away with
all of the consequences from it let's
you know let's run a race right we never
got there and so since we didn't get
there we can now turn a blind eye and
say well we did away with the racism
everything else must be the result of
the innate differences which it just
isn't you mean that's not to say unites
differences might not explain some of it
but we don't know that it does because
we haven't seen the experiment run
[Music]